okay listen I know this is gonna sound
insane but according to multiple sources
that I've interviewed over the last
couple of weeks
ESL told multiple Rainbow six siege
teams to break the law players casters
and coaches we're told to lie to
Japanese border officials all because
ESL didn't want to bother getting them
visas this story is nuts - giant
disclaimers Before we jump into this
okay so first off this story is ongoing
which means that things could change
over the coming weeks and - out of fear
of punishment most people that I've
talked to for this wish to remain
anonymous so this past weekend Rainbow
six Pro League finals took place in
Japan now pro league is run exclusively
by ESL and ESL as a company is broken up
into country-specific branches and the
branch that runs everything pro league
related is ezel Poland um I would say so
I started with us though and this is to
clarify cuz I know this gets confused a
lot whenever we talk about it on Twitter
publicly or whenever even people ask us
about it from the public this is SL
Poland just specifically we've dealt
with ESL America ESL Italy we've dealt
with plenty of other ESL branches before
this is specifically ESL Poland and have
they have not been been great partners
for famous Exige the ESL Poland has
strict they have an exclusivity for all
of Rainbow six anything pro but no
matter what no matter if you're working
or playing an event it's ESL sanctioned
you're paid by ESL whether you're a
player or talent or I don't know staff
behind the scenes or something at the
end of the day your paycheck still comes
from ESL Poland the vibe that I've
gotten from both the r6 community and
the sources that I've talked to is that
is how Poland is an absolute [ __ ] show
when general managers from these various
teams emailed ESL about what to do when
they got to the border without proper
visas ESL management told them to tell
officials that they were there to
spectate an event not playing one what
this basically means is that ESL told
them to straight up lie to border
officials
and we have the emails to prove it okay
so you're about to see a bunch of emails
that I was sent but first you need to
know that we've redacted all of the
identifying details in order to protect
our sources the first email example
shows a general manager asking an ESL
employee what exactly they want them to
do when they get to the border in this
second example well this is the email
that shows that ESL straight-up told
them to lie at the border and on top of
those two this third example sent to the
caster's basically says the exact same
thing if that wasn't enough we have text
and discord messages between players
talking about how they were told to lie
at the border about why they were coming
to Japan all of these examples I've just
shown you basically say hey don't say
[ __ ] about working in eSports event
pretend you're here for tourism okay so
in a second I'm gonna break down visas
just to make sure that we're all clear
about how they work on a very basic
level most countries allow you to stay
in the country for 90 days on a short
stay tourist visa short stay visas are
for tourism only you can't make any
money if that's the only paperwork you
have if you do want to work there's an
entirely different visa application and
additional paperwork that you have to
file now you might be wondering why the
help teams are reaching out to ESL about
visa applications since technically you
have to file all that paperwork yourself
that's because ESL sent out emails like
this which basically reads as fill out
this paperwork send it back and we'll do
the rest now according to ni peace
general manager instead of helping them
file the paperwork like they said they
would yes l just turned around and said
hey not our problem anymore and because
of that despite a social media shitstorm
and emergency attempts at securing visas
it didn't matter
phase I on and three members of NIF
didn't get their visas and didn't make
it to the pro league finals in Japan all
of this is unfortunately really normal
and highlights a systemic problem
throughout eSports now obviously people
made it into Japan there was still a
tournament and people won [ __ ] but we
don't know if they were able to secure
visas outside of the SL if they lied at
the border if anybody lied at the border
at all this situation is still super
unclear now I've reached out to ESL for
comment about all of this and here's
what they had to say the players is visa
in
it was very unfortunate for all parties
and we are currently investigating what
exactly went wrong in the first place we
are also improving the process already
making sure this will not happen again
after facing issues with visas due to
miscommunication we worked closely with
all parties to investigate various
opportunities to still fly in players on
time applying for tourist visas was
indeed one of these options we supported
nip and faced clients significantly to
gain last-minute visas due to
miscommunication we were able to secure
visas for almost every player
participating and even adapted our rule
set for additional standings ESO is
basically saying that they didn't have
enough time to properly secure the right
visas for players and coaches going to
pro league finals
instead they told them to use the
tourist visas which in this case is
still wrong okay so just to recap all of
this insanity the r6 community blew up
after ESL allegedly dropped the ball
when it came to helping teams secure
visas for the pro league finals players
from nip and phase weren't able to
attend and ESL stayed quiet throughout
the whole thing and then we found out
that ESL poland told casters and players
to lie at the border and that's it for
now like I said off the top this story
is still developing and I'm still
chasing down a bunch of other leads
which means when I know more so will you
you asked me how I would say it to him
that's how I would say to him I would
say it to you that way my [ __ ] mind